this is the the latest prediction
numbers Vivek ramaswamy tied in second
place with Ron DeSantis and uh you know
I think he might he might overtake Ron
DeSantis in the uh it's for second place
very very soon
When Donald Trump gets indicted Vivek
comes out with a very very strong and it
seemed unscripted message about how this
is wrong
whether or not you trust Vivek he is
he's rolling twenties he is he is
hitting all of his marks he's responding
authentically and properly he's
answering the questions when people
criticize him he tackles him head on now
he is rising in the prediction market so
I suppose we shall see at what point he
hit second place but uh I'm already
seeing a ton of trump supporters saying
that if for some reason Trump was
completely incapable of running The Vape
would be their guy
it's definitely interesting he sent out
a couple uh fundraising emails this week
saying I am on track to overtake uh Ron
DeSantis and when he was here the other
week he was saying like we were hoping
to read about reach about a 10 in the
polling by the end of the year we are we
are much farther ahead of that his
campaign really has had a lot of inertia
behind it what do you guys think what do
you think uh I know I think Vivek will
take him over I think Ron is plummeting
and I'm kind of heartened by it because
uh I heard you guys in the show the
other day saying vivik's kind of like a
a right-wing Obama and I I it's funny my
buddy Reed Coverdale actually said the
same thing about Ron at one point where
he was kind of following a similar kind
of thing but it's it's almost like the
people kind of saw it because I'm of the
opinion that I mean maybe Ron would be
great when he got in but I I'm sensing
neocon Vibes so it really feels like no
no Ron so I'm saying like he kind of was
the right wing Obama but now it's like
it's kind of that idea was like
traditionally politics being or modern
political experience now it's like Vivek
could be that right wing Obama to where
he's like I don't know maybe he will
swap when he gets an don't know maybe
he'll stay true to BJ he is genuine I'm
I'm unsure but he seems pretty genuine
from every time I've seen him talk but
point being is it's just I'm heartened
by the idea that people kind of lost
faith in the wrong thing like I love to
be clear I love him as a Florida
Governor I think he's great but now when
you get the reins of federal power
that's a different story now you're
controlling foreign policy Vivek is he's
going on every show and just saying ask
me yep and it's just raw unfiltered and
authentic it's it's masterfully done
whether he's you like him or trust him
or not if if he is being duplicitous and
political and trying to earn votes he's
good at it he he's yeah he's the best
I've ever that's the scariest part right
it's the ones who are really good at it
that's the ones you have to worry about
is the ones who are really really good
at hiding it until the last moment right
and he has done a very good job about
that because I think anyone who has even
base level political knowledge sees him
and sees some type of comparison to
Barack Obama but I would also maybe
posit that people who are now paying
attention to politics especially of
people who lean right are far more
informed on these issues so if he's
going to fool them it will be a lot
harder to fool them than to fool a
political novice in 2008 you can't just
put up a hope post you can't hold up a
hope uh you know a hope and change
poster and call it a day yo uh uh Viking
vet told us to he super chatted saying
pull up the predicted graph and you can
actually see if has already surpassed a
santis on on one occasion I think if we
let's go back 30 days we can see that uh
yeah there is a period where uh Vivek
and DeSantis had tied and then on the
28th Vivek actually surpassed DeSantis
by two cents and held that uh lead for I
believe two days so they tied in and now
it's it's going back up so he's already
gotten it I think uh
I think the story of Vivek is that he
was very much
apolitical he was kind of just like
somewhat political and then the story he
told us was that when the when the BLM
riots happened people came to him and
said change your company's profile
picture to the black square and he was
like oh sure whatever and he does
when they come to him and they're like
now write a letter about why what
happened was bad and he was like sure I
guess and then he writes like hey the
writing is really bad it's unfortunate
what happened I hope this country can
come together and heal and they were
like no no you're supposed to be why
we're right and support us and he was
like okay now you're pissing me off like
I I I wrote something then he started
getting board members from his company
resigning it seems like Vivek was this
successful what is he worth half a
billion dollars he's running a
pharmaceutical company minding his own
business probably very pleased with
himself at 37 and then woke activists
started attacking him
and look it's one thing if you're like
an indie game developer or a small
YouTuber or a random guy who works at a
steel mill and they're coming to cancel
you it's another thing if you're the guy
who founded a multi-billion dollar
pharmaceutical and you're worth half a
billion dollars and they come at you and
try to cancel you and then I'm just
imagining him sitting there like
clenching his fist being like I will
destroy you and now this is the story he
told that like after seeing that he
realized how dangerous this stuff was he
wrote the book I think what capital he
started talking about ESG being a
problem he created a a
um was it a mutual fund he created a
fund I'm not I'm not a finance guy
specifically to reject what's going on
with ESG and all that and then he's like
I'm gonna run for president so that this
dude's just just he's doing an amazing
job he's nailing it I'm a big fan he
seems to be fitting in more like with
the well-informed voters who would
naturally vote Trump you would have
thought they would have gone towards Ron
because he was such a culture War issue
type guy but those issues whether we're
talking about financing from companies
like BlackRock or Vanguard pushing back
against that type of cons of ESG based
capitalism is going to be strong for him
because the people who would vote for
Trump if he was out of the election are
going to care about that stuff and Ron
can't seem to land much of it we did a
clip the other day where he's like at
like some meet and greet with people and
he just laughs really awkwardly and
walks away and it's just like he can't
win like he like the clip is bad it's
not even his fault in this case right
but somebody poisoned it just seems
awkward and the the dude can't catch a
break honestly I found an endearing
personally because I'm like no that's me
yeah but like right now he's in like he
he's facing people who are very much
antagonistic right so that's going to be
that's not going to be shown in a way
that's endearing to people like certain
people might see it that way like you
said you you identified with it because
I would I would be that way you know at
the party too but in general that's not
something you want in the the leader of
your of your military right I think I
think what's cool about the vix
messaging is that it's more than just
like you know Ronda Sanders did a lot of
really interesting things culture wise
especi when it comes to gender ideology
one of the things I like about vivek's
campaign is that it's much more about
the renewal of like Civic engagement and
about patriotism and about values that
bring us together and I think as much as
like the more divisive aspects of the
culture War are definitely worth
fighting it is nice to also say like
here is actually what we want instead of
just saying well we don't want these
things what do we want and I think
that's cool there are definitely stuff
about like the campaign that I don't
personally agree with I think there
should be more restriction on legal
immigration he doesn't but I am grateful
that he's on the scene because he's
provoking a lot of really interesting
conversation I would describe Donald
Trump's campaign in a single word
Revenge I I don't see a lot more I mean
he's fundraising they're coming after me
they want to destroy me and strike fear
and I'm fighting for you and I see all
of this and I'm like Trump wants to go
in there and get revenge I like it
someone's got to go in and and have a
beef to just start firing the
bureaucrats and that's a great first
step towards fixing the problems in
government not all of them you know
government itself is a problem in many
ways and then you have Vivek ramaswami
and I look at him and you and and if I
were to describe his campaign it's like
you said Civic engagement he's talked
about Civics tests for voting he's
talking about
um American values and things like this
and he's he's he's nailing it
my question for you guys I guess is how
would you describe Rhonda Santos's
campaign like his policies what he's
pushing what he stands for what
represents like what does he represent
he's just not picking something he's
trying to be this essentially the of
Avec in a sense or like some sort of
Vivek you know Trump but he's not really
well I just mean the vibe like and then
he's but he's not really committing he's
also still kind of like sort of like
being like Oh to what like Elite talking
points kind of like eluding a little bit
but I might still be for that like it's
like there's so many things like I don't
want to use waffling I think on the
Ukraine stuff a while but he was talking
about it and he was just kind of like
can you really just not say no like just
we're done like and none of this like oh
we need to have a presence here and then
like just none of this like politician
talk people are over it they want you to
be solid about what you want and like
take a strong stance I think he has this
pull between his like Ron with his base
and his donors I think that is kind of
what the issue is so he's like where do
I go and it's like you got to pick one
or the other I mean preferably the base
how was it hard though I mean what
single voter actually is is voting for
more money being sent to Ukraine
I mean maybe maybe like Ukrainian
Americans the donors somebody who has a
connection to Ukraine yeah the thing is
I felt like Ron DeSantis was the
strongest when he was just around
DeSantis in Florida thinking about
Florida doing what he could for Florida
and he didn't have what I assume he now
has which is this kind of what you're
talking about like a donor class that's
come in and say okay this is what we
think will translate best to the
National level and in that way he's lost
his sense of self which like you're
saying when you have strong contenders
who have these personalities their
campaigns have a rhythm they have sort
of found found their their Niche uh in
terms of the interview circuit it's very
different than sort of where Rhonda
Sands is right now and again that's not
to say that he doesn't ever have any
interesting talking points or anything
like that but you start to feel like he
is not catching the Rhythm that he needs
to to sustain his second place standing
that's unfortunate man
I feel uh I feel let down yeah the uh
that uh video you guys have been talking
about a lot recently I think was a
perfect example where like they're
trying to sort of which one the the one
with the Ukraine or the Stars whatever
the heck it's called yeah yeah which
personally I thought was awesome but
like obviously no not I don't think the
Nazi said the video the whole vibe of
the video it was like how do you
accidentally put a spinning black sun
behind your candidate with with soldiers
marching towards it that's not an
accident yeah and if you're gonna do it
if you're gonna do it you need to own it
you probably shouldn't do it but if
you're gonna do it you shouldn't you own
it just be like hey it was a cool symbol
there it's stupid trying to own it but
trying to do this in between thing where
like our people put it out and we're
trying to have this plausible
deniability it's just silly either do it
or said I don't know I saw from the
Ukraine Fighters yeah so that we that's
what it was all about solidarity yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
unsung answered members only shows
exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time